so you eventually start driving a cab
you buy a cab and you start a business
for yourself in no no I never know I
didn't buy rented I rented a taxi from a
Russian owner that owned the taxi and I
paid a premium to have it every week and
I drove and picked up fares and had a
job as a Los Angeles County certified
taxi driver and you enjoyed it I loved
it
what did you love about it the freedom I
loved what happened was I had become so
wrapped up in a career for so many years
that and I was so dependent on others to
give me a sense of self-reliance that
became an anguish for me to not be able
to control my own destiny every morning
that I woke up became something that
became intolerable for me at some point
that groveling to your agent or hoping
that they call or the insecure meaning
you know they're going to return my call
because I have a question and I needed
answered and they don't because you
didn't you know you're not on the
priority list and you have to deal with
those things as everyone does but it
became very and the inauthenticity of
the business sometimes and the
interrelationships of that became
something that I didn't enjoy you see
you have a lot more autonomy as an actor
when you're a series regular on a show
or when you're when you've you know
you've made it or whatever
it's a different landscape than when
you're a working actor the two
landscapes are different so yes I found
a lot of great this new world had
refound itself to me which was myself my
control of my own destiny if I want to
make money today I get in a taxi and I
make money if I want to take my wife out
for you know dinner and I don't want to
because I'm a residual check didn't come
in the mail I can do that I don't have
to wait for my agent to tell me what to
do when to do it how to do it I would
just go do it and I enjoyed that and the
freedom of driving and talking to people
and the the whole novelty of it
so you were still trying to book rolls
though at the same time or yes I was
working through this as a matter of fact
I started booking work like crazy would
simultaneously with the taxi and I think
because I got some pressure relief from
the I think something to do with the
fact that I knew there was something
else I could do
gave me a less of an attachment to the
to to to to the acting right that I was
able to let that go enough to actually
start doing better work essentially and
I wasn't as wound up at the audition as
much pressure on myself so it kind of
released that pressure enough for me to
start doing better with my with my
acting so yeah I started working and
driving the cab to the set and parking
it proudly and rapping from a huge set
and getting in my cab in driving fares
and I loved it I was I I loved every bit
of it and so you think that the casting
directors sensed maybe less and I want
to call it desperation but yes but no
absolutely yes less something I don't
know what that something is that
something that people feel even in life
when you feel someone wants something
too much just that same transference of
energy I think it's very very much
prevalent in an audition
so yes also in the way you function and
operate you know suddenly the confidence
of having the key I would say confidence
is the word because suddenly having the
taxi became a way to be to feel like I
don't need you as much anymore you see I
don't need this I'm here to do this I'm
not here in need of it I have the taxi
so I'm not interested in this anymore
and suddenly that kind of had Murphy's
Law of life
applied here yeah and it's something
that can't be faked no no no that can't
be faked no if you if you you can't fake
you can't fake pretending that it
doesn't matter they see that
would you pretend that this doesn't
matter I'm you know that's an act and
that's if it's real it's real if it's
genuine it's genuine so so you would say
maybe to other actors you know as
cliches as fine a hobby but or something
finds an outlet whether it's a family
whatever something that you can hold on
to so that you don't feel that that role
is gonna make or break sort of who you
are yes absolutely I would say that when
I was happiest as an actor it was when I
was able to do - work work work on my
audition right and then I would have to
mentally tell myself this turns off at
five o'clock in the afternoon it's over
I don't think about this thing again I
bust my ass on this audition from 7:00
in the morning till 5:00 that's my time
I'm allotting that time for this work
when that five stops I now focus
mentally and emotionally on others my
life my friends my people you have to do
that if you're gonna mentally you know
what I'm saying hold on you have to have
that separation in that autonomy it's
very important yes to find to find a way
to turn it off and have something else
that grounds you because the in
certainty of trying to become an actor
or sustaining an acting career or even
once people have careers those pockets
of time of not doing things you know in
this business are treacherous I mean
you're not in control of when you're
going to do what you're going to do most
of the time that's a fact
so yes it's important to be to have that
outlet I think yes yeah certainly
you